it was a warning [ __ ] right good morning
guys so today is a very busy day right
now I'm in the parking lot of a grocery
store and I'm gonna go inside and buy
supplies for dinner later on today and
so today is a really busy day right now
Casey is getting ready we're gonna have
some friends come over to our house and
they're gonna do an interview so our
friend Brandon he has a clothing company
called Greenacre and on their website
they they'll interview people and like
just pretty much tell their story I did
one a while back I'm not sure if it's
still on the website but they usually
changed the stories and they changed
whoever they interview and so Casey's up
next and he's gonna be interviewed about
filmmaking and his life with filmmaking
I'm not really too sure what he's doing
but that's what he's doing today he's
gay he's at home getting ready for that
since today's a busy day I told Casey
I'm like hey how about I go get the
groceries today because it will take
turns sometimes he'll get up sometimes
I'll get him so whenever I come and get
the groceries he'll tell me what he
wants me to get since he's the one
cooking and I do the cleanup so that's
the way we team up in our marriage he'll
do the cooking and I'll do the cleanup
so in order for him to guide me on what
to get for dinner tonight we're gonna be
using this app called dab kick and full
disclosure this video is sponsored by
dab kick so thank you so much type kick
so right now I'm going to dab kick Casey
and so he can tell me what ingredients
to get for dinner tonight because I'm
clueless it's this app where you can
live stream with your friends or family
or with the public or however many
people you want really and then you can
share videos you can share photos you
can share music so you can all listen
simultaneously to whatever song you're
listening to you know you could send a
photo to the group and you're all
live-streaming together and the really
cool thing is that it has like a
built-in like web search so you can
search for videos photos music all that
stuff and so we've been using it
recently and we found it really useful
in times like this where I'm trying to
communicate with him or like send photos
back and forth or we're trying to figure
something out and it's been easier using
this app since it's like super fast real
time it doesn't lag so this app is
available to download for free on
Android
and IOM so yeah that's pretty much how
you use tap cake it's pretty easy it's
pretty cool so make sure to check it out
for yourselves with the link in the
description let me know what you guys
think of it yeah on to the rest of the
day today we are shooting for Green acre
which is Brandon's brainchild fashioned
Street where company you did a research
on me oh that's great we went to college
and almost oh yeah sale oh yeah so I did
I did get put on academic probation with
my first college experience and as
punishment or a not even a punishment
just that the outcome of that was for me
to go to full sell and to further pursue
my dreams so it wasn't a punishment it
wasn't a punishment it was just the fact
that my dad saw the potential in me and
he wanted to just keep pushing me along
even though I had a little bit of a
hiccup with my first college experience
so that's how much my dad believed in me
loved me and continues to push me to go
forward with this you know dream of mine
so I like watching you guys work you
guys remind me of me when I first moved
out to LA and it's cool that it's the
two of you once a director one's a DP
and both you guys edit because that
partnership I actually had with a good
friend of mine with a K and we went to
film school together he specialized in
lighting and camera opping and being a
DP and I specialized in directing you
know working with talent talking to them
blocking all that kind of stuff and both
both of us actually edit as well so the
partnership that I had with a cake I see
that in you guys so it's really cool to
see you guys working on stuff outside of
JK stuff like how many projects have
worked on so far shoot know the resume
let's go through the resume here we go
it's pocket in the past like maybe three
months yeah
that is tight so many this is coming out
of nowhere thanks to Casey by the way
with Jason Chen oh yeah that's right
that's right we worked with a law firm -
all right so I got home a little early
today did a terrible job at vlogging
today cuz I did not take you guys on
their journey that was today just
because I got dizzy I don't know but
yeah I just finished my meeting with
Bart and Joe and I'm excited to go pick
up Isaac right now because it's it's
actually tips turn to pick up Isaac but
since I'm back home a little early I
figured we could surprise Isaac with a
little bit of double parent pick-up day
time to shoes time I'm gonna go say
Hannah TIFF and then head over to Isaac
school sounds really good what a time
yeah I learned all the colors today oh
you did two hours today
but I learned color so quiz me I can
quiz you okay uh red blue lungs it green
looks okay
I feel like you know way more Spanish
then I know Cantonese I just started
lying and it's so hard like my mouth is
all tingly because I'm not used to
speaking this language so it all feels
like whoa my mouth is like whoa what
have you been doing all day today
and then like I've been trying to do it
home like I put the dropping it near
throat it's really hard you can quiz me
more colors tell me more
pink I'm homesick oh I didn't think you
would actually get that one because I
didn't think that was like a primary I
could color that they would take black
okay okay that's like about all the
colors I know some mom's like okay yeah
dark blue okay here's the ultimate test
Rojo Azul i'ma do
[Laughter]
Isaac Isaac was next to me one of it was
doing starting to learn X I wanted him
to learn it with me the first one that
he got was so cute the way you say yeah
it means you don't understand yeah
you're saying like I feel like I'm
making fun of the language by trying to
sound exactly like it conscious about it
because like it's easy for me to hear
whatever they're saying but then for me
to say it that's the hard part cuz then
I'm like it feels like I'm trying like
I'm making fun of it like that one like
the moment I'm like I just feel like
it's like silly I don't know and I like
the same for me in Spanish too like when
I subtract try and do Spanish like I try
to sound like a Spanish speaker rather
than like a like a gringo trying to
speak Mexican and and then do you always
tell me like I sound like Speedy
Gonzales you know and so I'm like you
make it seem like I'm making fun of it
but I'm trying I'm not yeah I just
between Spanish and Cantonese is because
Cantonese have has tones so I understand
why you say it this exact same way I say
Spanish because you think it's a tone
thing but it's not it's just say like a
soda however you're watching I just have
to be a so but they like you'll copy me
the way I'm saying it cuz I guess
because of Chinese and you I don't know
but yeah hopefully I was cute eventually
I could get to the level of just like
speaking to your family in Hong Kong or
our family in Hong Kong and just being
able to be on the phone well you can
tell them color so you can describe
colors to them now oh why are you guys
been asking me to put a paper towel
underneath the cutting board I'm
dead-ass thank you for the
recommendation
[Music]
[Applause]
that was the first time I really said
honey and then I just let it flow making
it seem like it's not weird at all
because I never call you that but I like
it I'm gonna adopt it I'm calling you
honey well you are cooking Isaac and I
went upstairs and we're meditating and
then it just Isaac really sleepy you
tired you know what though I have a
surprise
after you finish dinner I'm gonna show
you some raisin hey didn't wake him up
didn't work maybe I'll show you a
[Music]
present let's see first it takes
practice
yeah because I learned all this stuff
too like eating with the nice and stuff
when I was his age too but it didn't
really you couldn't pick it up until I
got with my teens it's like a motor
skill just kind of yeah like feeling
comfortable with it like it never felt
comfortable for me until I was like
maybe 14 15 I guess in my house like
really like 10 manners and like no
elbows and like just like really about
table manners so I think I was I 10 when
I learned how to properly eat and have
to hold my fork the right way I can't be
like a caveman
they feel me no elbows that's good
I like the lady I have here yes oh I
know why
chopsticks we didn't use the 14 knife
that offbeat our household is chopsticks
primarily so I think that's the reason
why I didn't pick up a knife important
so much later how is it amazing it's my
take on Cuban food
I know where'd you put in the bees in
the rice it tastes okay blimey it's raw
alright it is present time alright we're
done with dinner are you excited - I'm
so excited because it's the present
we're not in the past
[Music]
oh girl wait now huh don't get too
excited we need to curse this was sent
to us by a fan rock Tolentino rod thank
you so much space X rocket
it's the Falcon 9 and fairing flying
model rocket kit Ron you are so sweet
this is what runs up to you he said
Isaac I'm sending you this space X model
rocket is cool you turned your room into
a rocket / spaceship you can build this
model as they display or with your mom
and daddys help watch it for more
information
Southern California rocky Association
the tiffanykaye see my name is Ron
Tolentino and I have worked in aerospace
for the past 25 years last 10 have been
with SpaceX and now Virgin orbit it is
so nice to see the next generation grow
into space admirers and/or adventures
take care and best wishes
Ron Tolentino PS big fan of your work
and vlog thank you so much Ron this is
awesome
must eat fugu when I open this I was
like freaking out for you I'm like I
think it's gonna love this you can
actually built this and have it up with
your Clubhouse z we'll get this is cool
rocket and you know you have an uncle
that's trying to be an astronaut too
yeah mrs. Boren I'm you actually
internet message it's trying to be an
astronaut in the future so hey Ron baby
hey we can put you up when Andrews
graduated bees fly this baby yeah it
doesn't a letter we can even launch it
and stuff then I feel the part but
you're so tired right you're so silly
you know I shouldn't have given it to
him right before bedtime I was just so
excited
okay so we're you're gonna have to save
this activity for a weekend and then
maybe you can blog that and then
shoulder on how we watch it going to do
that yep okay now we gotta go sorry I
got you all excited right before bedtime
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]